yo Ottawa Dwayne Johnson yes I just
spoke Japanese I've been working very
hard on my Japanese alright more to come
later I want to say a very special hello
to audiences all across Japan I am so
excited to share this awesome Japanese
trailer from my new movie rampage now
having been to Japan multiple times
I know Japan is home to some of the best
kaiju movies the best but this movie
will excite more than just the kaiju
fans because I fight huge I'm talking
about huge monsters that just keep
getting bigger and bigger our Japan get
ready okay cuz I've been working on my
Japanese so here we go killed a guy kaga
tomaranai yes I think that was good
enjoy rampage children come on someone's
mutating animals and monsters we're in
trouble
[Music]
- lagos touch everything off Montiel
betánia and let's go save the world
[Music]
non-pc to do die done - is there
something in the river I was just
thinking the only thing that's missing
right now is the giant crocodile though
COO mom did they've got good night or no
call a rescue Jorge he was 2 years old
he's not just a friend he's family
don't move a muscle are you crazy don't
move
very funny you and I laughing at your
joke new guy you know bad he cry you can
get up now
and check your diaper come on let's go
where your message about George he okay
George it's okay
is in mirrors he considerably bigger no
he's definitely bigger need to find
someone who knows exactly what the hell
this thing is
I found her no that's a lie technically
she found us what's happening to my
friend are you familiar with genetic
editing changes would be incredibly
unpredictable increased strength George
speed agility
fails and change the chain run Where's
George I need to see him he is dangerous
for me to turn the man
we've created the next chapter in
natural selection project rampage works
we've got another one of your little
science experiments running around what
do you mean
of course the wolf lives
this time we throw everything we can at
these things and get people the hell out
of that city let's go save the world
that's a big arm don't fight it
you know there are other ways of dealing
with people I do know that yeah but
that's not fun
George okay ready to do this buddy
it's weird you like hang out with
animals more than people yeah well
animals get me a rescue George he was 2
years old
George never would have survived on his
own
he definitely trusts you last night
George was seven feet away 500 pounds
George you okay buddy you're scared it's
okay this morning is nine feet pushing a
thousand what's happening to my friend
familiar with genetic editing changes
will be incredibly unpredictable is he
the only one oh you didn't know about
the 30-foot wolf hello the day huh
science experiments falling from the sky
having George on that plane it's big
mistake I think we'll be all right
let's go save the world
it's coming back to me
you have to evacuate Chicago George
didn't ask for this they're gonna put
them down
that's not happening
[Music]
there's something in that River was just
thinking the only thing that's missing
right now is the giant crocodile
you